you know what people say about you
because it's hurtful but you can't be
immune to it a bloke on the tube said to
me last week ed miliband goes into a
room with Vladimir Putin the door is
closed two minutes later the door is
open again and Vladimir Putin is
standing there smiling and Ed Miliband
is all over the floor and pieces that
David Cameron who emailed us you know it
wasn't I don't think he uses the tube
very much but that's rather unfair to my
age it is unfair yeah but you understand
what the point is here the point is
people think you're just not tough
enough well let me tell you right let me
tell you okay
let me tell you okay in this in the
summer of 2013 this government proposed
action in Syria the bombing of Syria
right I was called into a room by David
Cameron and Nick Clegg because President
Obama had been on the phone the leader
of the free world right I listened to
what they said and over those days I
made up my mind and we said no right now
I think standing up to the leader of the
free world I think shows a certain
toughness
I would rather what's happened in Syria
since I'm not proud of it no it's a
failure of the international community
but what I'm not going to do is repeat
the mistakes of the 2003 Iraq war which
happened when and when labor was in
power which is a rush to war without
knowing what your strategy is and
without being clear about what the
consequences would be I'm not a pacifist
so I did support action in Libya David
Cameron talked about how I supported
action against Isis but am i tough in US
huh tough enough hell yes I'm tough
enough you think